Bitte schön.
Vielen Dank.
Hallo Guten Tag. Mein Name ist Kapaggan. Ich bin SUŞU-TENDIGI Assistenz Ersten Tehthich. Mit Ihnen würde ich gerne das Aufnahmegespräch führen.
Befovia über ihre aktuelle Bechwerden sprechen möchte ich ein paar Allgemeine frage stellen. Sind Sie damit einverstanden?
Ja, das machen sie.
Wie heißt du?
Ich heiße Hans Brenzla.
Können Sie bitte Ihren Nachname büchtern?
Ja, B, R, E, N, Z, L, E, R.
Okay, Herr Brenzla.
Wann sind Sie geboren?
Am 7. Mai 1940.
1940. Sie sind 72 Jahre alt.
82, hoffen Sie sich.
82.
Wie schwer sind Sie?
Wenn ich das so genau sitze, wiegt mich eigentlich so oft zwischen 70 und 75 kg.
Wie groß sind Sie?
Früher war ich mal 168 kg. Ich hoffe, das bin ich immer noch.
168 kg.
Okay, Herr Brenzla, was kann ich für Sie tun?
Ja, also, was ich halt merke in letzter Zeit, dass ich so Schwierigkeiten habe, mich zu konzentrieren.
Und ich kann mich so schlecht an Sachen erinnern. Ich vergesse so viele Sachen.
Ich vergesse sogar die Namen von meinen Enkelkindern oder wann die Geburtstag haben.
Und ich habe auch, was ich einkaufen will, dann gehe ich los.
Und dann stehe ich im Laden und dann überlege ich, was wollte ich jetzt eigentlich kaufen.
Und dann fällt es mir überhaupt nicht wieder ein.
Und ja, solche Sachen passieren mir halt in letzter Zeit.
Und das errat mich und da habe ich gedacht, da muss ich mal nachhaken, was damit los ist.
Verstanden. Herr Brenzla, seit wann haben Sie diese Beschwerden?
Ja, das fängt ja beim Alter immer mal so an, dass man sich an irgendeinem Namen nicht erinnert.
Oder dass einem nicht mehr einfällt, wie der Film gestern Abend im Fernsehen war.
Oder dass man sich an irgendwas nicht so erinnert.
Aber ich würde sagen, das ist jetzt so zwei Monate, dass das eigentlich schlechter geworden ist.
Vergesstet Sie häufig Ihre Adresse?
Ne, also ich gehe ja jeden Tag eine Stunde spazieren und den Weg nach Hause, das kenne ich ja.
Das ist ja immer schon das Alte. Da kenne ich mich aus, da geht nichts schief.
Vergesstet Sie häufig Ihre Freundenname?
Ja, so wie alten Freunde, die kenne ich natürlich noch alle. Schwierig wird es mit den Enkelkindern.
Die sehe ich ja auch nicht so oft.
Da fällt mir manchmal auch nicht ein, wie die heißen.
Okay. Haben Sie am Herd vergessen?
Noch mal bitte.
Haben Sie früher am Herd Essen kochen vergiss?
Ob ich vergessen habe Essen zu kochen?
Ja, am Herd.
Ach so, dass mir schon mal was angebrannt ist. Nein, Gott sei Dank noch nicht.
Aber ja, ich koche auch nicht so viel.
Meine eine Tochter, die macht mir immer das Essen, richtet mir das vor.
Da muss ich das nur noch warm machen.
Manchmal muss ich nur tatsächlich gucken, ob ich das schon aufgegessen habe.
Hab ich jetzt heute schon gegessen oder nicht?
Muss ich tatsächlich dann überlegen und dann gehe ich in die Küche und gucke, ob das dann noch steht.
Aber auf dem Herd habe ich es noch nie vergessen.
Da bleibe ich aber auch immer daneben stehen, bis es warm ist.
Wie sind Ihre Beschwerden plösslich aufgetreten oder langsam?
Ja, das kommt ja nicht so.
Am Anfang macht man sich keine Gedanken, wenn man mal etwas vergisst.
Aber wenn das dann mehr wird, so wie jetzt, dann macht man sich schon Gedanken.
Aber ich denke, das hat langsam angefangen.
Sind Ihre Beschwerden sich im Laufe der Zeit verschlechtert?
Von Tag zu Tag verschlechtert?
Ja, also in den letzten Wochen sonst wäre ich glaube ich nicht hergekommen.
Am Anfang habe ich das nicht so ernst genommen.
Aber jetzt habe ich gemerkt, dass mir das wirklich auch schwer fällt, mich so zu konzentrieren.
Und manchmal weiß ich auch nicht mehr, ob ich mein Essen schon gegessen habe oder nicht.
Muss ich tatsächlich in die Küche gehen und noch mal gucken, ob das doch noch steht.
Oder ob ich heute mein Essen schon warm gemacht habe.
Und manchmal weiß ich sogar die Namen von meinen Enkelkinder nicht.
Einverstanden, ja.
Wie gibt es bestimmte Auslöser, zum Beispiel unterstresst oder unter Belastung?
Ich habe ja keinen Stress.
Ich bin ja alleine und alter Mann, Rentner, habe ja keinen Stress.
Aber wenn ich zum Beispiel beim Einkaufen bin und ich weiß genau, ich wollte irgendwas kaufen,
dann stehe ich da mit meiner Einkaufstasche und dann weiß ich wirklich nicht, was ich kaufen wollte.
Und dann kaufe ich nur irgendwie eine Tüte Nudeln oder so, damit ich nicht ganz umsonst gegangen bin.
Und das ist natürlich ein bisschen doof, das ist dann schon ein bisschen stressig.
Das ist unser Internet zusammen.
Ich kann nichts mehr hören und sehen.
Kann ich wieder etwas hören?
Okay.
Pergessen Sie Ihre Schlüssel zu Hause?
Das ist mir zum Glück noch nie passiert.
Aber der hängt auch immer direkt am Narbel neben der Wohnungstür,
dass ich da nicht aus dem Haus gehe, ohne den mitzunehmen.
Unser Not hat aber auch meine eine Tochter, die mir immer das Essen bringt.
Die hat auch noch eine Schlüssel.
Wenn ich da also tatsächlich, dass man vergessen würde, könnte ich auch zu der hingehen.
Okay.
Waren Sie beim, okay, waren Sie wegen dieser Beschwerden bei Anderem erst?
Na, bisher war ich da noch nicht beim Arzt.
Und Sie haben sich früher bei Anderem verschwerden?
Nein, das habe ich so noch nie gehabt.
Haben Sie Lemung?
Nein, nein, nein, zum Glück.
Nein, ich kann nicht laufen.
Ich kann mich überall bewegen, ja.
Ich gehe jeden Tag eine Stunde spazieren.
Haben Sie Fieber?
Fieber habe ich jetzt nicht gemessen, aber ich fühle mich nicht fieber.
Nein, schon lange kein Fieber mehr gehabt.
Leiden Sie unter Schüttefrost oder Nachtschweiß?
Nein, sowas habe ich nicht.
Gusten Sie?
Gusten?
Nein, wie Gusten habe ich nicht zum Glück.
Leiden Sie unter Atemnot oder Herzrasen, Herzklopfen?
Ja, also mit dem Herzen, das ist nicht so weit her.
Ich habe so ein bisschen eine Herzschwäche.
Und ich muss immer meine Tabletten richtig nehmen,
weil ich sonst so dicke Beine kriege.
Aber wenn ich jetzt meine Tabletten vergesse,
dann habe ich Probleme, die Treppe hochzulaufen.
Aber normalerweise komme ich ganz gut zurecht.
Wie ist Ihr Appetit, wenn Sie nicht vergessen?
Ja, der Appetit ist nicht mehr so wie früher.
Früher konnte ich ja gut essen.
Was war es ich?
Nach der Arbeit ist man nach Hause gekommen.
Unterwegs hat man seinen Mittagessen gegessen
und hat sich so viele Kollegen zusammen.
Da habe ich immer viel Appetit gehabt.
Aber seit ich alleine bin, seit meine Frau verstorben ist,
habe ich nicht mehr so viel Appetit.
Ja, mein Verständnis.
Da ist das Leben natürlich auch nicht mehr so erfreulich.
Da quält man sich manchmal so durch die Tage.
Trinken Sie Genukosa täglich pro Tag?
Trinken tun ich lieber nicht so viel.
Ich muss nachts immer so auf die Toilette gehen.
Wenn ich so viel trinke, dann muss ich so oft gehen.
Deswegen trinke ich eher nicht so viel.
Ich trinke also morgens eine Taste Kaffee.
Und vielleicht auch mal zwei zum Frühstück.
Und dann beim Mittagessen, wenn ich es nicht vergesse,
trinke ich da eigentlich so ein Glas Wasser dazu.
Und beim Abendessen trinke ich dann nochmal so zwei Tassen Tee.
Und dann vielleicht noch mal zuvor im Schlaf gehen.
Noch mal einen Schluck.
Aber viel trinken tue ich bestimmt nicht.
Okay.
Vielleicht können Sie an den Küchern,
neben Ihrem Bett eine Eselbrücke
oder eine Notiz,
oder ein Karte, das Wasser trinken.
Dass ich mich daran erinnere, dass ich mehr trinken soll.
Ja, aber dann muss ich nachts so viel auf die Toilette.
Wissen Sie mit der Prostata.
Da muss man ja so oft laufen.
Und bevor ich mir in die Hose mache, trinke ich lieber ein bisschen weniger.
Okay.
Ihnen übel?
Nein, eigentlich nicht.
Nein, müde bin ich so ein bisschen.
Ja, so schlapp.
Fühlen Sie sich alschöpfen?
Ja, das kann man wohl so sagen.
Ja, ja.
Ich glaube, manchmal verschlaffe ich auch in meinem Sessel ein.
Wenn ich da so sitze, dann merke ich,
ich, im Fernsehen ist ein ganz anderer Film an als vorher,
das fällt mir dann schon auf.
Ja, dann schlafe ich wohl mal zwischendurch ein.
Okay.
Wie viele Stunden schlafen Sie täglich?
Oh.
Am Nacht.
In der Nacht?
Ja, oft kann ich nachts nicht einschlafen,
dann wählt sich mich so ein bisschen rum.
Aber und dann werde ich zwischendurch wachen
und dann auf die Toilette halt.
Aber vielleicht so sechs Stunden oder so in der Nacht,
sechs, sieben Stunden.
Sie leiden unter Prostata?
Ja, die Prostata ist halt, in meinem Alter kann das ja mal passieren.
Wie viel mal müssen Sie auf Toilette?
Ach, je nachdem, zwei, drei Mal in der Nacht.
Zwei, drei Mal.
Dann kann ich nicht wieder einschlafen.
Wie ist Ihr Schulgang? Leiden Sie unter Verstopfung oder?
Ja, manchmal klappt das nicht so gut,
dann habe ich tagelang nicht so richtig Schulgang.
Ja.
Ist Ihnen schwindelig?
Wir zum Glück nicht, nein.
Okay.
Haben Sie mit Ihrer Kopf geschlagen oder hatten Sie Unfall?
Sie meinen, ob ich irgendwie mit dem Kopf verletzt habe?
Nein, nein, nein.
Also klar haut man sich mal den Kopf irgendwie am Schrank an
oder so, aber jetzt nicht, dass ich irgendwie eine Platzwunde hatte
oder dass da irgendwas Schlimmes war, nein, nein.
Herr Brenzler, haben Sie Prostata?
Seit wann leiden Sie unter Prostata?
Ja, das ist bestimmt schon fast 20 Jahre.
Ich bin da schon 82.
Okay.
Haben Sie äußer Prostata, chronische Erkrankungen?
Ja, also wie gesagt, ich muss ja so Tabletten nehmen,
ich muss so Tabletten nehmen.
Das eine, das ist glaube ich für das Herz, ne?
Weil das Herz, ja, das ist halt nicht mehr so stark.
Und dann, wenn ich meine Tabletten nicht nehme, dann, ah,
dann komme ich die Treppe nicht hoch und dann, ja,
und dann kriege ich auch so dicke Beine, ne?
Und beim Spazieren gehen Schwellen mir die Hände an
und ja, und dann kann ich die Treppe nicht mehr so gut
hochlaufen und dafür muss ich dann Medikamente nehmen
und dafür, ja, also mit dem Herz ist nicht so gut, ne?
Hatten Sie früher Herzinfarkt?
Ein Herzinfarkt? Nee, das habe ich nie gehabt.
Okay. Seit wann nehmen Sie diese Medikamente ein?
Oh, schon lange, schon lange, ja.
Und dann hat man auch irgendwann mal festgestellt,
dass der Blutdruck ein bisschen zu hoch ist
und da nehme ich auch schon lange Medikamente ein.
Da, damit ich das nicht vergesse,
mache ich mir immer so eine kleine Schachtel für jede Woche,
damit ich dann immer gucken kann, ob ich alle Tabletten genommen habe.
Manchmal vergesse ich es dann auch, ja, das merkt ich.
Haben Sie momentan eine Rezepte?
Ein Rezept? Ja.
Also immer, wenn die Tabletten alle sind, muss ich zum Arzt gehen, ja,
dann muss ich mir neue Rezepte holen.
Oder Arzt-Belief, haben Sie?
Ein Arzt-Briech? Nein, da müssen Sie meinen Hausarzt fragen.
Wie heißt der denn noch?
Das fällt mir jetzt nicht ein.
Ich muss mal in meinem Portemonnaie nachgucken,
da habe ich so einen kleinen Zettel.
Warten Sie mal.
Oder nach dem Untersuchung können wir kontr Hö.
Dann suche ich Ihnen das mal raus nachher, ja.
Wie heißt der denn noch?
Leiden Sie unter Suckerkrankheit?
Nein, zum Glück nicht. Nein, nein, nein.
Also Essen kann ich schon alles.
Ich habe eigentlich nicht mehr so viel Appetit.
Sonst meine Frau gestorben ist,
muss meine Tochter mir immer das Essen bringen,
das warme Essen.
Ich habe noch so Frühstück und Abendessen, mache ich mega selber.
Und da muss ich einkaufen gehen,
dann muss ich immer gucken, dass ich alles dabei habe.
Sie nehmen nur Prostate wegen Prostate Tablete
und gegen Haaschwache Tablete ein.
Nehmen Sie ein Zettel.
Ich habe hier so ein Zettel, ich lehse Ihnen das mal vor,
das eine heißt Furose Miet.
Dann nehme ich noch Spirulatum.
Und dann habe ich auch noch ein anderes Medikament,
das muss ich auch morgens und abends nehmen,
das heißt Candesatan.
Und wenn ich nachts so gar nicht schlafen kann,
wenn ich nachts so gar nicht schlafen kann,
dann habe ich mir so Baldrian Kapsel geholt.
Die habe ich mir selber gekauft.
Und wenn ich das Gefühl habe, ich kann gar nicht einschlafen,
dann nehme ich davon eine.
Okay, Herr Brinslan, wurden Sie früher operieren?
Operiert? Nein, eine Operation hast du glaube ich noch nie.
Haben Sie Allergie oder Unverzwecklichkeit gegen etwas?
Oh ja, tatsächlich, eine Katze darf mir nicht ins Haus.
Da kriege ich so einen Schnupfen und da kriege ich ganz rote Augen.
Also bloß keine Katze, ja.
Haben Sie alle Gurude im Funken erhalten?
Ja, geimpft bin ich.
Ja, ich habe auch die Corona-Impfung bekommen, ja.
Vollständig gegeben, ja.
Ja, ja, da habe ich drei Impfungen bekommen.
Waren Sie im letzten Zeit im Ausland?
Nein, nein, nein.
Mein alter reise ich nicht mehr.
Nein, nein, ohne meine Frau, da verreise ich schon lange nicht mehr.
Herr Brinslan, rauchen Sie?
Nein, geraucht habe ich tatsächlich nie in meinem Leben.
Das habe ich gar nicht erst angefangen.
Trinken Sie Alkohol oder haben Sie getrunken?
Ja, also ein Glas Wein trinke ich schon mal, wenn ich Freunde treffe.
Das passiert nicht so oft.
Sind ja nur noch wenige über, ne?
Dann trinke ich wohl mal ein Glas Wein.
Gelegentlich.
Ich kann mal wo so sagen, ja.
Frau Brinslan, diese Frage nehmen Sie sich nicht persönlich.
Das ist nur medizinische und allgemeine Frage.
Nehmen Sie Drogen oder früher?
Drogen? Aber Sie meinen das nicht meine Tabletten, ne?
Nein, Drogen habe ich nie probiert, nein, so etwas.
Was meinst du, ich bin im Brich geboren, da gab es sowas nicht.
Einzelstand.
Okay.
Leben Ihre Eltern noch?
Oh nein, überlegen Sie mal, ich bin 82, da können meine Eltern wo nicht mehr leben.
Aber ich habe auch keinen guten Kontakt zu denen gehabt.
Ich kann Ihnen nichts über meine Eltern sagen, das ist schon alles zu lange her.
Okay.
Gibt es in Ihrer Familie wichtige Erkrankungen?
Zum Beispiel, Ruckelkrankheiten, nörlige Krankheiten oder Bluthochdruck?
Ich kann nur von mir selber reden.
Das habe ich Ihnen ja gesagt.
Ich habe ein bisschen Bluthochdruck und ein bisschen Herzschweche.
Aber von uns in der Familie gibt ja keinen mehr.
Und meine Töchter sind zum Glück alle gesund.
Wie viele Kinder haben Sie?
Wir hatten drei Töchter.
Und eine wohnt hier noch zum Glück in der Nähe und die guckt immer mal nach mir.
Haben Sie Geschwister?
Nein, ich brauche alleine.
Wie viele Enkeln haben Sie?
Ich meine, das sind jetzt sechs.
Ja, aber sechs sind das ja.
Aber die sind auch schon alle groß.
Die gehen schon aufs Gymnasium.
Aber wenn ich mir die Namen da habe, manchmal vergesse ich, wie die heißen.
Ja, das ist schwierig.
Die Elbinen sich ganz nicht daran.
Was waren Sie von Beruf?
Ja, ich habe früher in der Autoindustrie gearbeitet.
Sie haben schon gesagt, dass Sie alleine leben.
Ja, das ist richtig.
Meine Frau gestorben ist, bin ich alleine.
Ich verstehe Sie.
Aber Ihre Töchter lebt in der Nähe von Ihnen?
Ja, die kocht immer für mich und bringt mir dann das Essen.
Und dann muss ich mir das Mittagsloh warm machen.
Ja, das ist okay.
Herr Brensler, ich möchte für Sie ein bisschen zusammenfassen.
Ja, Sie haben seit zwei Monaten Schilette erinnern.
Ja, ich kann mich schlecht an Sachen erinnern.
Das stimmt, ja.
Besonders Enkelnamen.
Ja, aber auch andere Sachen.
Wie heißt der noch mal mein Hausarzt?
Neuer, bekannte Personen erinnern Sie sich nicht daran.
Ja, das kann ich Ihnen alles erzählen.
Ja, klar.
Ich weiß, dass meine Frau auch in der Schule ist.
Das weiß ich auch noch.
Aber wie mein Hausarzt, wie heißt der noch?
Ich muss das für Sie auf die Zelle gucken.
Neuer, bekannte Personen erinnern Sie sich nicht daran.
Manchmal vergessen Sie, ob Sie essen.
Ja, das ist mir schon mal passiert, dass ich nachgucken musste,
ob ich noch essen kann.
Ich habe auch keinen Hunger.
Ich habe keinen richtigen Appetit.
Dann merke ich das auch nicht, ob ich schon gegessen habe.
So viel ist man ja auch nicht mehr im Alter.
Früher haben Sie nicht ähnliche Beschwerden.
Nein, das ist ziemlich neu.
Sie leiden unter prostata vergrößerung und erschwache auch.
Ja, das ist richtig.
Nehmen Sie drei Medikamente,
spironolakton und kandersalatan 1.
Ja, so heißen die ja, genau.
Bei Bedarf nehmen Sie bald dran zur Schlafen.
Zum Schlafen, ja, richtig.
Ich habe immer auf dem Nachtisch liegen.
Wenn ich nachts aufwache und nicht wieder einschlafen kann,
dann nehme ich da diese kleinen Trages.
Herr Brensler, haben Sie in letzter Zeit ab oder zu genommen?
Ich wied mich ja nicht so oft.
Aber ich glaube, die Hosen sind so ein bisschen weit.
Ich glaube, ich habe ein bisschen abgenommen.
Wann waren Sie beim Herzarzt oder Kardiologie?
Beim Kardiologen.
Ach, das ist schon länger her.
Da hat mich mein Hausarzt mal hingeschickt.
Und dann hat er mir seit immer die Medikamente,
die der Kardiologe verschrieben hat,
die hat er mir dann immer weiter verschrieben.
Okay.
Möchten Sie etwas hinzufügen?
Nein, also, ich habe Ihnen ja gesagt, deshalb ich hier bin,
weil ich das Gefühl habe, dass ich irgendwie Sachen vergesse
und dass ich immer vergesslicher werde
und dass ich mich nicht so gut konzentrieren kann.
Ja, deswegen bin ich hergekommen.
Okay, verstanden.
Okay, Herr Brensler, ich habe von meiner Seite
alle wichtigen Fragen gestellt.
Jetzt möchte ich Sie körperlich untersuchen
und dann werde ich Blut abnehmen
und bei Bedarf Ultraschall veranlasst.
Und kann man da feststellen, woher das kommt?
Ja, nach der Untersuchung und mit der Chefarztbesprechung
kann ich Sie bestimmte Diagnose stellen.
Ja, da bin ich einmal gespannt, was dabei rauskommt.
Ja, okay.
Kann man Dein Tablet nehmen dagegen, dass das wieder besser wird?
Ja, ich denke, Sie haben vergangen,
vergessliche Probleme.
Ja, deswegen will ich auch nicht mehr so vergesslich sein.
Ja, nach der Untersuchung und Besprechung
kann ich für Sie bestimmte Diagnose stellen
und vielleicht Therapie auch...
Ja, das wäre schon gut.
Dann warte ich bis nach der Untersuchung ab,
was Sie mir dann sagen.
Okay.
Ich glaube, das war für mich ungefähr genauso anstrengend wie für Sie.
Ja, erste Mal habe ich diese Alarmnöse hören.
Ja, okay.
Gibt es Fragen?
Brauche ich ein paar Minuten.
Ja, alles klar.
Gibt es Fragen von den anderen?
Eine Frage gestärkt hat,
haben Sie das bewusst sein verloren
oder haben Sie schwindelig?
Schwindelig hat sie gefragt,
aber bewusst sein verloren hat sie tatsächlich nicht gefragt,
aber habe ich nicht.
Und wenn würde ich mich daran erinnern?
Was waren die Nachdemengel-Umses-Kollegen bei der Anemnese?
Eigentlich hat sie komplett gefragt.
Und sie waren natürlich heftig unter Dampf,
weil ich ständig dasselbe erzählt habe.
Ich war ja kein besonders kooperativer Patient.
Und sie musste auf sehr geduldig auf mein ständiges Wiederholen eingehen.
Ich finde, sie hat das ziemlich gut gemacht.
Und so direkt Fehler,
oder Probleme habe ich jetzt nicht wahrgenommen.
Ich habe Frage.
Als Patient eine Frage,
eine Situation zeigen.
Meine Frau hat tot gestorben.
Was ist die Reaktion?
Wir haben hier schon mehr darüber gesprochen.
Ich finde, das kommt sehr drauf an.
Wenn jemand sagt, meine Frau ist vor letzte Woche gestorben,
dann würde ich sagen, das tut mir leid,
das ist sicher eine schwere Zeit für sie.
Aber wenn jemand in dem Alter sagt, ich bin versittet,
nichts näher dazu sagt,
dann würde ich da nicht mehr darauf eingehen.
Vielleicht könnte man noch nachfragen,
ist das schon lange her?
Er hat gesagt, seit meine Frau tot ist,
habe ich keine Freude mehr.
Das wäre eine Möglichkeit gewesen,
wo man nachhakt.
Ihre Frau fehlt Ihnen sehr.
Sie fühlen sich einsam.
Das kann man schon machen.
Ich würde jetzt nicht mehr sagen,
herzliche Beileid.
Wenn sie vor einem halben Jahr gestorben ist.
Sondern eher auf die Situation eingehen.
Ich würde sagen,
ich fühle mich offensichtlich alleine.
Ich bin traurig, dass Sie sich nicht mehr überlegen.
Das kann man durchaus machen.
Das finde ich schon okay.
Ich frage mich,
wie die Frage ist.
Wer sich drogen probiert,
der Patient hat 82 Jahre alt.
Richtig oder peinlich?
Es ist ein Problem.
Das ist eine interessante Frage.
Er nähern sich gesund.
Sie spielt das wahrscheinlich
in diesem Alter keine Rolle mehr.
Man muss mal ganz ehrlich sein.
Die Generationen der Drogensüchtigen,
die hier in Deutschland praktisch
nicht mehr sind,
die in den 60er-70er-Jahren
waren,
die Leute, die in den 60er-70er-Jahren
angefangen haben,
Drogen zu nehmen.
Wenn die bisher überlebt haben,
dann sind die tatsächlich so.
Das ist eine Frage,
die sie nicht mehr erlebt haben.
Dann sind die tatsächlich so weit.
Natürlich muss man auch sagen,
dass heute Drogen
auch wieder sehr gesellschaftspfähig geworden sind.
Da bin ich nur
manchmal sehr naiv.
Ich glaube, es spielt keine Rolle.
Es spielt keine Rolle für mich.
Es spielt für mich keine Rolle.
Es gibt auch Szenarien,
wo das heute sehr dazu gehört,
das, was ich koche,
in zu konsumieren.
Oder irgendwelche Exzesse pülen.
Vielleicht ist es gar nicht so ganz aus der Welt.
Dass man danach fragt.
Offensichtlich ist es ja so,
dass die Prüfer auf diese Frage wertlegen.
Wobei ich immer finde,
wenn man die jetzt so betont,
wenn man sagt, nehmen Sie es nicht persönlich,
dann denke ich immer, man gibt der Frage so ein Gewicht.
Man betont das so sehr.
Es war dann eben ganz klar,
habe ich hier lesen können,
eine Frage ernähren Sie sich gesund.
Da ist natürlich die große Frage,
was versteht man unter gesunder Ernährung?
Wahrscheinlich würde der das jetzt bejahen.
Keine Ahnung.
Aber natürlich hat er eine viel zu kleine Trinkmenge.
Das lag ja offensichtlich auf der Hand.
Die eine Frage konnte ich mir auch noch einmal
überlegen.
Ich habe das jetzt auch noch mal überlegt.
Die eine Frage konnte ich jetzt nicht.
Ich habe nur einen Abschnitt gesehen.
Erinnern Sie sich an die,
genau, das ist der Punkt.
Er erinnert sich nicht an die Sachen aus der letzten Zeit.
Da fehlt Ihnen das.
Aber das, was lange zurückliegt, das weiß er.
Er kennt noch die Namen von seinen Kollegen, von der Firma.
Aber er kennt nicht die Namen von seinen Enkelkindern.
Die er letzte Woche gesehen hat.
Das ist der Klassiker natürlich.
Dass man das neue nicht erinnert.
Das alte aber sehr wohl.
Gut, können wir?
Da ist keine Frage.
Klar.
Wann wurde bei Ihnen das letzte Mal Blut abgenommen?
Wenn er das noch weiß.
Aber es ist schon eine Weile her.
Ist das Ergebnis normal?
Sonst hätte der Hausarzt ja etwas gemacht.
Wahrscheinlich hat er nach allen Dingen geguckt.
Ich denke mal, das war unaufhällig.
Die Blut untersucht.
Das war unaufhällig.
Und sind Sie vegetarisch?
Nein.
Ich bin vegetarisch.
Nur ich.
Eine Situation.
die Patientin, der Patient erinnert sich nicht die letzte Zeit, was sie gemacht haben. Wie können
wir vertrauen, was er gesagt? Ja eigentlich überhaupt nicht, das ist ja das Problem. Das ist
das Problem. Man muss rausfinden, wer der Hausarzt ist und muss die Hausargen überprüfen. Oder
vielleicht fragen wir, mit wem hat er uns hier gekommen, allein oder haben seine Freunde deine
Freunde verwarten. Ja, also wahrscheinlich. Begleiten die Personen. Ja, ja, aber er ist
allein gekommen. Er hat ja gemerkt, dass irgendwas nicht stimmt. Ja, aber man kann
tatsächlich seinen Aussagen nicht so 100%ig vertrauen und sicherlich muss man
die Aussagen verifizieren über den Hausarzt. Ja, das ist klar. Und unter
Umständen kann man ihm auch sagen, wenn sie das nächste Mal zu uns in die Praxis kommen,
vielleicht keine ihre Tochter mitkommen. Die Tochter, die immer das Essen kocht. Ja,
dass man das nochmal zusammen bespricht. Ja, aber für mich war das natürlich jetzt auch,
ja, tatsächlich ein bisschen schwierig. Es gibt also diesen Fall, den habe ich mir jetzt nicht
aus den Fingern gesogen. Ja, es gibt diesen Fall und aber ich habe natürlich versucht,
ihn auch irgendwie annähernd überzeugend zu präsentieren. Ja, dass ich eben nicht nur sage,
ich vergesse Sachen, sondern dass ich auch tatsächlich Sachen vergesse. Ja, in sofern.
Aber klar ist so eine Ananie so super schwierig. Okay, sollen wir? Ja, ich habe eine Frage. Können
mir fragen, zum Beispiel, sind Sie aggressiv oder fühlen Sie sich aggressiv direkt fragen?
Ja, also da würde ich vielleicht sagen, sind Sie manchmal wütend?
Oder so, ne? Und aber meinen Sie wirklich aggressiv oder meinen Sie depressiv? Ja, beide
eigentlich, die Assam, Assam oder Demenz der Patienten, Patienten haben ein bisschen
aggressivität und Depressivität auch. Ja, wobei die Aggressivität kommt, glaube ich,
in dem Augenblick, wo sie merken, dass die anderen etwas merken. Ja, ich erinnere mich an eine Freundin,
die ihre Mutter zurzeit betreut und die also sagt, zwischendurch ist sie total wütend, dass die
Tochter die zweite Zeitung abbestellt hat. Sie kann die Zeitung sowieso nicht lesen. Ja, und die Tochter
hat halt gesagt, Mensch, wir brauchen so viel Geld für die Pflege und für alles. Eine Zeitung muss
reichen. Ja, und jetzt kommt immer wieder, du hast ja meine Zeitung abbestellt. Ja, also das
weiß die Mutter dann wieder. Da erinnert sie sich daran, dass sie früher die beiden Zeitungen
gehabt hat. Sie erinnert sich aber nicht mehr, dass die Tochter ihr ganz vernünftig erklärt hat,
warum sie diese zweite Zeitung abbestellt hat. Ja, oder ja, dass sie sagt, du hast mir ja meinen
Schlüssel weggenommen, weil die Mutter für irgendwelchen Tageszeiten aus dem Haus weggelaufen ist.
Ja, du hast mir gerne Schlüssel weggenommen, du bist böse. Ja, und dann werden die Leute
aggressiv. Wahrscheinlich wird dieser Typ hier noch nicht in der Phase sein, sondern erst, wenn
ihn jemand mit der Nase drauf stößt und sagt, hör mal, wir müssen das ein bisschen anders regeln
und er merkt, dass dann das ja eingeschränkt ist, dann wird er wahrscheinlich aggressiv. Möglicherweise
sagt die Tochter, wenn sie mitkommt, ja, wenn ich versuche, ihm die Tabletten zu kontrollieren,
dann seht er böse. Kann passieren, dass sowas kommt. Aber denke mal, der ist ja noch in
einer relativ frühen Phase hier. Okay. Okay. Ja, hallo Frau Obererstin. Ja, schon Guten Abend.
Haben Sie kurze Zeit? Ja, natürlich. Sie haben einen neuen Patienten gesehen? Ja, ich habe einen
neuen Patienten, Herr Brensler. Herr Brensler ist 280 Jahre alt und 1,68 Meter groß und ungefähr 70
Kilogramm schwer. Herr Brensler hat sich in unserem Krankenhaus wegen vor zwei Monaten
begonnen, der Demenz vorgestellt und er ist ängstlich und außer dem klackte er über Bein ödeme
und ja, die vegetative Anamnäse, äh, oder ins Sonia, äh, oder ins Sonia sind unaufnellig,
in letzter Zeit, äh, habe er, äh, abgenommen, äh, ich habe die Hose royal,
Ja.
Habe ehe abgenomen, aba er weiße nicht wie viel kilo er abgenomen habe.
Er habe er leider unter Nocturie in der Nacht Müsteer zwei oder dreimal wassalassen.
Und sein Appetit habe in Leicester-Seit ziemlich vermindert.
Er erinnere sich ganz nicht daran, ob er es gegessen habe.
Ja. Die Vorerkrankungen erleiht an Prostata und
Hyperplasi.
Prostata Hyperplasi und Kronechiaherz Intifizient,
Ernehmweggen, Kronechiaherz Intifizient, Prosomit, Sipronolaktan und Kandersartan
Ein.
Hat er auch einen Bluthochdruck?
Ja, er leiht an Bluthoch-Arteriele-Hypertoni und
seine Bluthochwerte sind sein Grenze.
Ernehmweggen, Kronechiaherz Intifizient, Prostata Hyperplasi
Okay.
Bislang sei er keine Operation.
Er sei bisher nicht operiert worden.
Ja. Er sei kein Raha,
Ertrinke gelegenen Alkohol, Drogen wurde ferneinzt.
Er ist bekannt.
Er ist in der Familie Anamnese.
Er hat keinen Kontakt mit seinen Eltern.
Er ist wohl schon lange tot.
Er ist 82 Jahre alt.
Er hat 3 Töchter, die auch gesund sind.
Er lebe allein.
Die Alkohol-Anamnese gibt es, dass er neue Bekannte-Personen,
Annoe-Bekannte-Personen sich nicht erinnern.
Er erinnere sich nicht an Essen.
Wie ist es mit der Vergangenheit, mit weit zurückliegenden Sachen?
Er erinnere sich an Vergangenheit.
Altefreunde und ihre Familie auch.
Er erinnert sich an seinen Eltern.
Er erinnert sich an die Namen der Enkelkinder.
Er erinnert sich an die Anamnese, die er erinnert sich an die Annoe-Personen.
Was kommen wir sonst noch in Frage?
Differenzialdiagnose?
Was viele Demens auch haben gedacht.
Schlaganfall.
Was könnte noch schlimmstenfalls noch los sein?
Was könnte sein?
Er ist ein bisschen ängstlich.
Er ist auch nicht.
Das würde ja auch sehr viel erklären.
Eine Altersdepression ist nicht ungewöhnlich.
Situation.
Eine Altersdepression.
Wir können die Depressionen mit.
Was machen Sie jetzt diagnostisch mit dem?
Ich kontrolliere.
Ich werde Blut entnehmen.
Welche noch zum Beispiel?
Was machen Sie bei der Körperlichte-Untersuchung?
Manche neurologische Testen.
Was ist dann der, wenn wir den Alzheimer-Verdacht nachgehen?
Was machen Sie bei der Körperlichte-Untersuchung?
Das haben wir gesagt.
Das wäre eine Idee.
Manche, die Analyse von der Angehörigen.
Dass der Patient mit Angehörigen kommt.
Das wäre auch vernünftig.
Ich habe noch als wirklich invasiv.
Eine der bekanntesten neurologischen Testen.
Ich habe das tatsächlich einmal erlebt.
Das war für mich sehr schockierend.
Das war für mich ein Schock.
Manche Kartetests.
Ich weiß nicht, ob das heute noch Standard ist.
Vielleicht kann jemand von den Kollegen dazu etwas sagen.
Kann irgendjemand von den Kollegen etwas dazu sagen?
Ich habe es auch durchgeführt.
Was würden Sie dem Patienten auf den Weg geben?
Es gibt Medikamente.
Was muss man mit dem Patienten auf den Weg geben?
Was muss der Patient im Alltag auf alle Fälle machen?
Er muss mehr trinken.
Er hat eine Trinkmenge von einem Liter.
Er muss deutlich mehr trinken, damit er besser durchblutet ist.
Er muss auf alle Fälle mehr trinken.
Ich bin gespannt, dass Sie mich auf die Lauchenden kommen.
Ich habe noch eine Frage.
Ich habe eine Erfährung.
Sie kennen sich aus der Tat.
Sie haben Patienten schon selber behandelt?
Sie hätte ich mit diesem Fall nicht aufs Blatt als führen können.
Ich denke, es war ein schwieriger Fall.
Ich hoffe, dass niemand vergessen, dass wir uns treffen.
Ich wünsche Ihnen einen schönen Abend.
Wir sehen uns dann.